- [Voiceover] In 2010,
this man, Forrest Fenn
hid a chest filled with
gold and rare artifacts
somewhere in the Rocky Mountains.
The search for this
million-dollar treasure
has obsessed thousands
of seekers worldwide.
And the trail starts with
this poem, which Fenn wrote.
It contains nine clues that point
to the treasure's location.
- It's here someplace.
Are we rolling?
As I have gone alone in there
and with my treasures bold,
I can keep my secret where
and hint of riches new and old.
- [Voiceover] Fenn's motivation
for hiding the treasure
was to give hope to those
knocked down by the recession
and to inspire them to explore the wild.
- I found a beautiful little
Romanesque treasure chest
and I started filling
it up with gold coins
and gold nuggets and
about 200 native rubies.
There are two ceylon sapphires,
there are eight emeralds,
a bunch of diamonds.
But mostly gold.
I don't know what it's worth
and I don't even want to think about that.
You're not gonna be disappointed
if you find that treasure chest.
(melodious piano music)
- I am Cynthia Meachum and I
am a full-time treasure hunter.
I have been looking
for Fenn's treasure now
for a little over three and a half years.
- I hid the treasure chest more than
8.25 miles north of Santa Fe,
in the Rocky Mountains some place.
Nobody knows but me.
- In the poem that you have
to solve, Forrest always said,
you have to find where warm waters halt
and to me this is where warm waters halt.
That's where I think we need
to find the treasure chest.
- [Voiceover] The thrill of
this chase for Fenn's treasure
has led many to leave the
safety of known trails
and well-beaten paths.
- The mountains are very unforgiving.
It's extremely important that
you know what you're doing
and you know where you're going.
You can end up in big
trouble really quickly.
There's even one hiker that's been lost
looking for the treasure and
he hasn't been found yet.
- [Voiceover] To Fenn's knowledge,
the treasure remains a hidden mystery.
But the real reward
should come from the hunt.
- I was positive this
was our warm waters halt
and unfortunately I don't think
that this is gonna be the spot.
It doesn't matter what
state you treasure-hunt in,
you gonna have beautiful
scenery like this.
And it doesn't matter if you
find the treasure chest or not,
this is finding the treasure.
Right here.
- So hear me all and listen good,
your effort will be worth the cold.
If you are brave and in the wood,
I give you title to the gold.
(soft piano music)